hello hi Steve you know I have to say
hello it twice because I'm setting it up
as a podcast with my blue snowball here
and at the same time I'm trying to
create this video so I recently posted
on my blog the linguist on language that
there was a person writing in the
National Post here at Canadian newspaper
who was a little critical of Barack
Obama for suggesting that Americans
should learn more languages she pointed
out that Barack Obama is unilingual
probably doesn't even have his kids
learning other languages who knows and
that there's therefore was hypocritical
I don't think he's hypocritical and I
posted this to my blog she mentioned
that in Europe people learn languages
because they have to because there's so
many languages there and in north
america there isn't the same mean and so
one shouldn't pontificate and sure i
agree it one shouldn't say you know i
speak a few languages you don't
therefore i'm better than you know other
people have different interests if
they're not interested in languages
there might be better people than
people's be lending it more intelligent
more generous you know however language
learning is still a very worthwhile
thing to do and I think the problem
sometimes is that it's presented too
much as an obligation it's either a duty
in Canada to learn French of your an
Anglophone we have all kinds of people
we have a commissioner for languages
says we shouldn't allow people to
graduate from university if it can't
speak French things of this nature and
press that's all wrong the minute you
make it an obligation people resent it
and then we have other attitudes towards
language and sometimes I find their cert
about there are there are three types of
people or three approaches to language
learning one of which is very good in
which I support and the other two are
not very productive the two unproductive
ones are either the minimalist
who says d wouldn't it be cool if i can
say thank you I'd like a beer please and
where is the bathroom in whatever
language and at the other end the other
extreme is the perfectionist who is
frustrated because they can't say
everything they want to say in the
language they're learning and to me the
successful language learners are those
that are in between to me it's perfectly
useless to learn to say 10 phrases in a
language I have never found that I could
go to a country and I've tried I mean
Indonesia or if I was in I don't know
latvia I will inevitably by a phrasebook
look through it try to say those things
but I have no sense of what I'm saying
and the person he doesn't understand me
or comes back in Latvian Indonesian and
I'm lost so to me that is just a false
dream that you can somehow pickup 15
handy phrases and actually do something
with it I don't believe it some people
might that's fine i don't and i think i
mentioned on my blog that I think
language learning is a bit like
gardening only in the sense that it's a
very enjoyable habit it's very good for
one and there is something positive and
constructive that comes out like a
garden or like the ability to
communicate so if you're going to have a
garden you're not just going to plant
three flowers and leave that's not a
garden you have to continue to cultivate
the garden plant more plants or flowers
remove weeds I mean there's an ongoing
activity there I incidentally enjoy
gardening while listening to language
audiobooks on my ipod but that's another
connection between gardening and
language now at the other end of the
other extreme is people who are
perfectionists you know I'm always
frustrated because i can't pronounce
this or because i don't feel comfortable
communicating with people and and so
forth and to me that's just silly you
will never
as comfortable in the second language
whatever your level is on that gradual
progression from zero to comfortable
fluency wherever you are be happy be
happy as long as you are cultivating
your garden your garden may not be as
nice as the garden next door that
doesn't make it a lesser garden it
doesn't take away from your enjoyment of
the guard so I think it's very important
to be in that middle ground of and I
find when I see sometimes YouTube's
where people are introducing languages
and it's it's along the lines of know
they'll be speaking in English and
they'll say well how do we say I in
French and how do we say you well we say
it this way and it's just so painfully
slow now people who for people who are
intimidated by learning a new language
I'm sure this is a good thing and I know
those kinds of podcasts are extremely
popular but I have never learned a
language that way again the approach we
take it link is listen to something very
simple 30 seconds 15 seconds the
beginner stuff we have it in both the
target language and in a variety of
other languages one of which hopefully
is a language understood by the learner
listen listen over and over again listen
to the language you go Majesty figured
out what which is I in which is you and
your brain will start to identify these
patterns especially if your goal is not
just to learn to say hello how are you
but your goal is to gradually let your
brain get used to this language and as
you become more familiar with it more
things make sense you learn more words
eventually the grammatical explanations
which at first are meaningless they even
start to help you recognize patterns and
it's a bit like a garden it's going to
take you awhile it's good at the garden
the first year
remember the first year at crawls the
second year it grows and the third year
at Leafs or something I mean language
learning is a bit like this it's a
cumulative it's a snowball it's getting
bigger and bigger and bigger all the
time and and the growth can be all of a
sudden quite amazing when you suddenly
feel hey I can understand that I didn't
understand that three months ago so yeah
just a brief comment there I guess that
that language learning shouldn't be an
obligation language learning is a very
it can be with the right approach a very
enjoyable activity very beneficial
activity is the brain and my preference
is to not content yourself with the sort
of hello how are you and why look at me
i could say things in 10 languages but
all i can say is hello and at the other
end no don't impose yourself on yourself
some obligation would be perfect make
mistakes as long as you can communicate
that's the goal and in that sense to
just well I'm suddenly had another
thought getting back to the whole
testing thing yeah I recognize that
there is a need for some standard
testing but I must say that I think
testing in language is not a useful
thing the only thing that you should
measure if I were student the only thing
I would measure is is the student
spending the time with the language some
people learn faster similar slower more
slowly some things will fall in place
earlier some things will fall in place
later the only thing you should really
be worried about is this person
listening is this person reading is his
person enjoying himself or herself is
are they spending the time on the task
and that's the only thing that really
matters anyway I might just do this in
in French or in some other language as
well